[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
what in the world was going on in 1844
well for starters karl marx writes his
economic and philosophical manuscript
forming the foundation for the communist
manifesto
the birth of communism 1844 charles
darwin completes his essay
on natural selection creating the
foundation for evolutionism
the famous german philosopher frederick
nietzsche who said
god is dead is
joseph smith founder of the mormons
is executed samuel morse
sends the first electronic message
saying
what has god wrought the oldest bible
in the borough in the world the
psychodex sinaiticus is discovered
in saint catherine's monastery on mount
sinai
and the industrial revolution is at its
peak
this was an interesting time in history
plus
a million people around the world
thought jesus was coming in 1844.
why stay with us friends we'll talk
about it
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
welcome listening friends to bible
answers live and we're so thankful
you've tuned in
and this is a live broadcast if you have
bible questions give us a call
phone number is 800 god says that's
800-463-7297
and you can call that number good chance
you'll get your question on tonight's
broadcast
if it's ringing just give it a moment
and our
operators will pick up and get you in
the queue
and for those who have the internet if
you want to join us you can see what's
happening here in the studio
and um pastor ross and i are dressed up
a little bit because we just came from a
religious
function and it's facebook it's the doug
batchelor facebook page
and the amazing facts facebook page
either one you'll see the program
beaming and streaming there and my name
is doug batchelor
my name is john ross and pastor doug
before we uh get to our
study today let's start with prayer dear
father we thank you once again that
we're able to
take this time to open up your word and
study and we do ask your blessing upon
this program
be with those who are listening lord and
they just guide us into a clear
understanding of what the bible says in
jesus name amen
amen well pastor you opened the program
talking about the year
1844 now it sounds like some very
important things seem to happen that
year
which really created a framework you
might say
for what was to unfold in the next 150
years of earth history but
there's something else interesting in uh
that you're 1844
it was also the culmination of a
religious revival and awakening that
centered in north america but also in
other places around the world
where people had a particular interest
in prophecy bible prophecy
there was a lot of studying of the
scriptures especially the books of
daniel and revelation yeah and in
particular there's a prophecy in daniel
chapter 8. this is the longest time
prophecy in the bible and there in
daniel 8 you can read in verses
oh i'll say verse 13 and 14 maybe start
with verse 12.
it says a beast's power is the context
would cast the truth to the ground
and he would practice and prosper then i
heard one of the holy ones these are the
angels that he sees in the vision
one of the holy ones was speaking to
another holy one
said to that certain one who was
speaking how long will the vision be
concerning the daily sacrifice and the
transgression of desolation
to give both the sanctuary and the host
to be trodden under foot
and he said to me for 2300 days
then the sanctuary will be cleansed so
this is a long time prophecy
and the starting point you need a
starting point to know what it's talking
about
is given in the next chapter the angel
comes and he says
gabriel says daniel i'm going to give
you understanding in the vision
and that from the going forth of the
commandment to restore and build
jerusalem
say jerusalem had been destroyed by the
babylonians
they were in captivity and finally the
persian king artaxerxes gave that final
command for
them to restore and build jerusalem it's
in your bible
in ezra chapter 7 457 bc
now in prophecy a days a year so you go
300 not days but 2 300
years to from 457
and that comes to 1844. and you see this
amazing shift happening in history at
this point
here on earth and you've got several
religious movements
that are born some may be counterfeit
but certainly a true one and at the same
time
christ entered the final phase of his
heavenly ministry
you know jesus is our high priest and
when he died on the cross
that was like the altar when the um you
first went into the sanctuary
and then you continue moving through the
sanctuary and there's the labor of water
and then you go into the holy place and
there's the
the bread and there's the light and
there's the altar of incense and
the bible tells us in hebrews jesus is
our high priest
now friends you know why we're talking
about this right now do you know what
today is for those who are listening to
the live broadcast
this is happy day of atonement this is
yom kippur
once a year the end of the year the only
time and the only person
who could enter the holy of holies was
the high priest
and jesus is our high priest and
prophetically he was completing
a special work of atonement or i should
say beginning a special work of
atonement
final judgment in 1844
and something was happening on the earth
now you know in the bible it tells us in
revelation there are seven churches
these are seven ages or epochs of church
history
the last age of the church is called
laodicea
that means the judging of the people
which is what happened during the day of
atonement
and it was a time when god's
people would humble themselves before
the lord they wanted to be prepared
to be cleansed from their sin as the
sanctuary was cleansed
and there was a special yom kippur day
of atonement service and that begins
sundown where you are in north
america and it was
mentioned in prophecy that in 1844 the
last
age of the church began christ's
beginner
entered into his final work of atonement
in heaven when he's done with that
michael stands up and there's a great
time of trouble
and we're living just it looks like
we're on the verges of that now friends
if you'd like to better understand these
prophecies about the sanctuary i just
skimmed the surface and what happened in
we've got a free offer that will show
you from the bible
we sure do pass today it's called right
on time and we'll be able to send the
study guide to anyone who calls and asks
and if you're fascinated to understand
some of these deeper truths of bible
prophecy
you've got to call and ask for the study
guide it's called right on time and we
delve into
daniel chapter 8 verse 14 that 2300
day or your prophecy to receive the
study guide the number to call is
800-835-6747
that is the resource phone line and as
for the study guide it's called
write on time again that's 800-835-6747
and ask for the study guide right on
time and pass it up maybe i just want to
quickly add to that uh
you actually spoke on the subject this
weekend
um and your sermon title i forget
1844 what really happened here you go
and you actually deal with some of these
uh prophecies
and it's just a great i think it's
available on youtube
or it's my posting monday on youtube
probably
so it might be a good idea for our
listening friends if you'd like to see
that we encourage you to take a look at
that and um
maybe even on your website it'll be on
my facebook page live
there we go you'll be the first person
they see okay
so they'll be able to see that uh we're
gonna go to the phone lines now we've
got uh
george listening in new jersey george
welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors how you doing
tonight good
i i wanted to mention that i just
received one of your
little booklets on the trinity i find it
very informative i actually
haven't read it through just kind of
breeze through it but i'll start reading
it but thank you for the
for the booklet oh praise the lord thank
you glad you're able to read that
yes i have a couple questions on the
millennium near the end of isaiah
verse chapter 65 verse 20
isaiah 66 verses 18 to 20. these verses
seem to be a little difficult to
reconcile
with the belief that during the
millennium the earth is
vacant of people you know it's it's
barren
and so i'm sure you've dealt with these
verses before but i
i know if you could explain a little bit
about that first one isaiah 65
20 because yeah talks about a time when
a child shall die a hundred years old
and sitter being accursed and
at first it seems like it's talking
about eternity but then it seems to be
talking about
something a little bit more where sin is
still existence
right what's your opinion on that one
yeah let me read this for our friends
that are listening george
it says here in isaiah 65 20 sp and keep
in mind if you go back a few verses it
says
for behold verse 17 i create a new
heavens and a new earth so
you read in ii peter it's very clearly
talking about when god recreates the
world
following the time when it's purged by
fire at the end of the millennium
and god then says in verse 20 confuses
people it says no more
well first of all it says no more is
there weeping no more has heard the
voice of crying
that's again like revelation 21 no more
tears no more death
and it says no more shall an infant that
live but a few days
yeah they had a high infant mortality
back in those days nor an old man who
has not fulfilled his days
for the child will die a hundred years
old now people go what
children dying i thought in heaven
nobody died a hundred year old child
this is actually a difficult verse
because of the translation
the word die also means cease and it
says
a child will not cease meaning to be a
child now that'd be remarkable if a
child is still a child at 65.
you know abraham didn't get um have his
first baby till 100
and you read in genesis a lot of the
early patriarchs that lived
long centuries they didn't even get
married until 90 or
or some of them older so
isaiah's simply saying that the child
will not even cease not die
he will not even cease to be a child
until a hundred
so it says they'll build houses and
inhabit them
they'll plant vineyards and eat the
fruit of them and as the days of a tree
so are the days of my people no one
keeps dates or age for a tree so it's
talking about eternity going on forever
it is talking about after the millennium
okay and then the other one was 18
through 20 of
isaiah 66 it appears we're talking about
the coming of the lord in verse 17
but then it talks about a time when
people are going to be
preaching the gospel or declaring the
glory among the gentiles
and if you look at it chronologically it
seems like it's happening after the lord
comes
so i want to know how you might explain
that a little difficult too
well i see yeah i can understand you
know the way that you read
the prophecies in revelation daniel
ezekiel
and some of isaiah they're not all
written chronologically
some of these prophecies are yeah
they're written so that
they often come in spurts isaiah doesn't
even talk about his caller conversion
until he gets to chapter six
and uh some of these are segmented it is
true that
the um it's telling us that the jews are
going to have a great revival
god's people bringing people to the lord
it says the gentiles will come to the
lord
several places in isaiah's writing he
mentions the same truth
so when you read it again here in
chapter 66
i don't think you should pin it
chronologically
you know there's three great comings
that the bible speaks of you've got the
first coming when jesus
came as a child a baby you've got the
second coming when it comes to the
clouds of glory and then you have the
third coming at the end of the
millennium
in the old testament some of the
characteristics of the first second and
third coming are presented
together and it's not until you get to
the new testament that you begin to
realize there's actually quite a period
of time between
the first coming the second coming and
then a thousand years before the third
coming
but the prophets when they looked in
history and they looked forward
a lot of the characteristics are kind of
put together and it's
the last part of the bible book of
revelation it kind of divides it up for
you
it makes a little easier to understand
thank you george appreciate your
question
we've got catherine listening in
washington state catherine welcome to
the program
yes hi good hi how are you doing
i'm doing well how are you great
good i really appreciate your program
it's wonderful
um my question is um
i was raised keeping the sabbath and the
holy days
and most of my life and then i did do
either one for a long time and then
finally after
your program and several others i came
to believe that the sabbath was
something that we should keep and i i
really believe that
and but it's separate from the holy days
and i have a friend
that i was raised in this religion with
who's 92
who believes that the sabbath and the
holy days are
the same you know the same and i'm
trying to figure out how to explain that
to her
that there's a distinction yeah well you
can
it very quickly and by the way we do
have
a a book so just before i forget that
we'll offer you that has a lot more
scripture than i can give you in just a
few moments
on should we keep the feast days and but
if you look in first corinthians chapter
verse 7 paul says therefore purge out
the old leaven
that you might be a new lump since you
are truly unleavened for
indeed christ our passover was
sacrificed for us
so when jesus died on the cross
keeping the ceremonial laws that pointed
to christ became
irrelevant now we still need the weekly
sabbath that's part of the ten
commandments that was not part of the
ceremonial laws
ceremonial laws came many years later
with the um
exodus and uh so when the veil ripped
in the temple the ceremonies connected
with the temple and its services
and this was at the death of christ they
were nailed to the cross
you read about that in colossians
chapter two these ceremonial
laws and ordinances were nailed to the
cross and
and now um you know we of course keep
the
we still believe in baptism and keeping
the the sabbath
but um not the ceremonial days
so you're there i'm here i'm here i just
i'm just i'm struggling with trying to
this woman has been in this for so long
she's 92 years old well
you know the best thing i can today is
young kipper yeah and i'm working
tomorrow and she said you're working on
the fast day how can you do that you
know and i'm just like wow i don't know
what to say
well you know get the book it sounds
like she's still pretty
sharp for her age get the book and share
that with her and
and just pray the holy spirit will work
on her heart again the number to call
for that is 800 835 674
that is the resource phone line and the
book is called the feast days should we
keep the feast days and
i think it's an important study so call
for that we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks if you're
outside of north america you can just go
to the amazing facts
website and get more information about
that
we've got daniel listening in arizona
daniel welcome to the program
hi how you doing pastors good and your
question
okay so um i just wanted to uh get a
little bit of clarification
um with respect to the uh
uh grounds for divorce obviously um
i i was asking a young lady there
if uh there's two
biblical you know things that i read
obviously the the in the old testament
god's commandment one of them says
thou shalt not belter um and then the
bible obviously says
that would be the grounds for divorce
but then
jesus alludes to that in the new
testament
but says that not only
do you adopt sir but if you think of you
know lust i think was it that's
that's the right ideology matthew 5 27
if you commit adultery in your heart
right yes so
which i obviously you i know the the
actual act
but can the thought also be um
no that's i'm glad you asked that
question because i've heard people say
that before that's a really important
question
thinking something in any country in the
world is not the same as
doing it now it is true christ is saying
salvation
is you need to have a change of heart if
a person is constantly
thinking about adultery and they're
viewing pornography and thinking
adulterous thoughts
then that's a sin they're committing
adultery in their mind but that is not
the same thing as committing the act of
course the act is reality
it's not just thinking the act involves
another person
no no country that i know of will uh
put you in jail for having a thought of
murder
you know now if they prove that you had
a plan then that's you know
intent to commit murder but if you in
your mind
think about committee murder that is
certainly not as bad as committing
murder
and so a lot of people they could say
well i'm divorcing my husband because
i found a playboy magazine in his house
in the house and
he's thinking those thoughts and that's
the same as adultery no
that's people are trying to widen the
door by doing that now i don't know if
i'm answering your question daniel
absolutely now i just wanted to be clear
on that so i just
uh wanted to know on the bible with
respect to the grounds of divorce yeah
it tells us um in especially there in
matthew chapter 5
verse 31 jesus tells the ground sounds
like you know that verse
i think he also mentions that same
passage in matthew 19.
now we have a book we can share with you
called marriage divorce and remarriage
if you'd like to learn more about this
or anyone
want to know more on what does the bible
say about marriage the number to call
for that is 800-835-6747
the book is called marriage divorce and
remarriage and we'll be happy to get it
in the mail and send it out to anyone
who calls and asks again that number is
800-835-6747
we've got anthony listening in new york
anthony welcome to the program
good evening pastors um my question is
based on uh
peter chapter 4 verse 12-13
and it reads uh beloved think it not
strange concerning the fiery trial
which is to try you as though some
strange thing has happened to you
but rejoice in as much as you are
partakers of christ's sufferings that
when his glory shall be revealed you may
be glad also with
exceeding joy and so my question is um
i i hear a saying that says uh if you
don't have
trouble in your life then you're
probably not doing something right
are you probably not living your life
right and i guess it's based on the
thought that
um satan does not see you as a threat
right he has no reason to cause problems
in your life so how do you know
is there any scripture that we can know
when adversity
is a sign of god's displeasure or is it
just
something that he's using to refine our
characters
especially if we're trying to do our
best to follow his will yeah but we
still have
problems and we start fiery trial how do
we make a difference yeah good question
you know if you look in same book first
peter chapter 3
peter says for it is better if it is the
will of god to suffer for doing good
than for doing evil
if you're going through adversity while
you're living a godly life
well then you're a threat to the devil
if you're going you know through
adversity because
you're drinking and driving and got
thrown in jail you can't say i'm being
persecuted for my righteousness
so good and bad comes to everybody you
know jesus said the rain and the
sunshine falls on everyone
and even job said after he went through
a lot of trials
said to his wife shall we not receive
good from the lord and also receive evil
and so it's a principle in the bible
that there's a battle going on
and there's a lot of uh casualties in
the fallout of that battle between good
and evil in the world
so everyone's affected but uh we want to
make sure if we are
going through persecution it's it's for
our righteousness and not our
wrongesness
so i don't know if that makes sense
yeah no that that does but sometimes you
just wonder
you know am i doing something wrong or
is this just
are you going through fiery trials right
now
uh you could say that in some ways yes
yeah well
i'll tell you we're living in the last
days and we pray the lord gives you
strength because jesus promises he'll
not allow you to
struggle or suffer more than you're able
to bear and that's first corinthians
chapter 10
but will with every temptation i give
you the courage to
to handle it and so yeah a lot of people
in the world are going through
some real struggles now with people lost
their jobs and
parents are going stir crazy the kids
won't go to school
staying home and uh yeah i think we're
entering you know bible talks about a
big time of trouble before the end
we might be going into a little time of
trouble soon
so hey thank you anthony and i don't
know if there's something you know we do
have a book pass today i'm thinking
about it's called when the brook
dried up and uh it's actually talking
about the christian going through trials
what do you do when trials come your way
and again the book the
book is called the brook uh dried up
why do christians suffer and i think
this is helpful for any christian
facing trials and difficulties the
number to call for that is 800-835-6747
and we'll be happy to send this out you
can ask for the book why do
christians suffer and we'll send that to
you next quarter that we have is
ashton listening from kentucky ashton
welcome to the program
oh hey how are you guys doing good thank
you for calling
yeah i really would like to thank you
guys for all that you've done
um you know i recently got baptized to
your um last sabbath
well praise the lord we love to hear
those testimonies
and what's your question tonight um
my question is um because i'm trying to
do some evangelism in my school
but my question is how do i deepen my
relationship with christ
to the point where my light can show to
others
so they can come unto jesus
yeah good good question you know there's
there there's three secret weapons
to strengthen our faith uh technically i
guess you could say there's four
and you find them in the holy place of
the temple
in that first room before you entered
the inner sanctum or the holy of holies
there was what they called the holy
place
there were three pieces of furniture
that outlined the christian's
secret weapon to growing you had an
altar
of incense and that represented prayer
tells us that in revelation i forget the
verse the
rep the altar is the prayer of saints in
revelation 16 is it
and then you had the table of shoe bread
which represents the word of god then
you had a candlestick
jesus said you are the light of the
world we are to be witnesses and let our
light shine before men
so if you are daily reading god's word
communion with the lord in a deliberate
way
and doing something every day to try to
share your faith and bring others to
christ
you will grow and then the fourth thing
i told you
do those things persistently and
patiently continue to do them
and get deeper in them revelation 8 4
talks about the prayers of the saints
ascending up before god from the altar
of incense
so hey we appreciate your question and
we do have a free book that talks about
the bible and
how it is an ultimate resource to have a
revival matter of fact we got a book
called 12 steps to revival i was looking
at that one yeah i was going to suggest
that's a great book
again for anyone wanting to learn how
you can have a deeper relationship with
christ the book is called 12 steps
to revival and the number to call is
three 800
six seven four seven and asked for the
book twelve steps
to revival pastor doug i'm looking at
the uh
the time we have about a minute before
we gonna take a mid break but
instead of taking a call uh we won't
have to cut anyone short but we do have
something exciting that's actually going
to start
next month october the 23rd and it's so
timely
it's talking about the series is
entitled revelation now
and you look at what's happening around
us in the world it seems as though these
prophecies of the bible are being
fulfilled
and they are hey listening friends we're
having a special program
where we're going to talk about what in
the world is going on right now in the
context of prophecy
and it's called revelation now this is
something nobody should miss
and we're making it free to everybody so
if in your group
whether you're meeting in your churches
or you're meeting in home groups
are you just by yourself anybody can log
on for free and participate in the
revelation now seminar we're going to be
talking about some of the
great prophecies of the times in which
we're living the second coming
antichrist angels armageddon millennium
we're going to we're going to hit all
the big ones friends go to
revelationnow.com and there at the
website it'll tell you how you can join
us
and be part of this uh movement i think
we've got 115 000 people so far
that have signed on as individuals and
about 500 different
churches and we think that number is
only going to expand
so we're going to take a break more
bible questions coming those of you
online don't go anywhere
we're going to be back and answer more
bible questions in just a moment
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets
political tensions are at an all-time
high does the bible have anything to say
about the times in which we are living
hi friends this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering
if the world's about to implode some are
fearful that global events point to a
coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7200
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live hello listening
friends we are back if you've tuned in
along the way this is bible answers live
and we've been doing this for about 25
years now
and inviting people to call in we'll
just do our best to answer bible
questions i remember when i first
started reading the bible it was just
there were a lot of mysteries there i
tried to understand and it was so
exciting to understand the truth because
the truth will set you free
so we've committed this program to that
purpose if you have a bible question
800 god says 800-463-7297
you can also watch what's happening in
our little mini studio here with pastor
ross and i and that's at the
amazing facts facebook page or the doug
batchelor
facebook page and that's me i'm doug
my name is john ross we're going to go
to the phone lines we've got jack
listening from colorado jack welcome to
the program
oh thank you for taking my phone call i
really appreciate it
you're welcome thanks for calling your
question
then i'm gonna kind of jump around a bit
because i'm ministering to a friend and
kind of talking with him
and he believes
we'll start with nero is the antichrist
and he also claims that
and believes that the first resurrection
happened
in matthew 27 50
and his biggest
argument that i can't really get around
is
in revelation 20 verse
3 where it says and
again i think this is kind of
loose water but he says and after a
short or a little season right
so so he thinks that a little season
after christ there would be a
resurrection
yeah he uses second peter 3 8. well
let's talk about it because
you've asked already you've asked
several big questions so can i jump in
and try and answer some of that
i'd love i'd love that okay uh first of
all
he i think he clearly believes in what
they call preterism there's three views
on prophecy preterism from the name you
can
tell it means pre they think that all of
the prophecies in revelation
already they got took place in the first
hundred years of christian history
i think nero was the antichrist and like
you said the resurrection there
at the death of christ was the first
resurrection problem with that
is you look in first thessalonians
chapter 4 it says the lord will descend
from heaven with a shout the voice of
the archangel the trump of god and the
dead in christ will rise
then we who are alive and remain will be
caught up well that clearly has not
happened
there's very few people that believe
preterism then another very popular view
it comes from dispensationalism and
darbyism it's
futurism it's what they call it they
take most of revelation from chapter
four
on they put it off in the future and
then you've got the historists and
pastor ross and i are in that middle
camp
we believe like many of the protestant
reformers that
you can see the panorama of history
beginning in revelation
john said the time is at hand it began
there and it reaches to the second
coming
and um yeah you know luther
spurgeon wesley zwingli all of the great
protestant reformers even calvin
they were historists in their prophetic
interpretation
so um yeah there's a thousand scriptures
we can give you that
explains the resurrection hasn't
happened yet that's an exaggeration not
a thousand but a lot
you there jack i agree yes i i'm
listening to you
and i i told my wife i was like i'm
going to call i'm going to ask this
question but they're going to say all
this
you've said everything that i've
expected you would say and
i hate to waste your time but i i love
to
get confirmation of what i've been
telling him and it's just
you guys have changed my life i've i
called in six weeks ago maybe three
months ago and i lived in las vegas and
i was pining away in las vegas i was a
musician in las vegas
just doing everything wrong that i could
do and the lord led me to colorado
and now my whole life has changed and
it's really
it's you guys are like pastor doug
specifically
you have been a blessing amazing facts
has just been a blessing to myself you
found the website jack
you're right you found the amazing of
course okay good
night i can't wait to watch your
your seminar on the 23rd starting
october 23rd i've already signed up for
it i can't wait unless you're right well
you tell all your friends and enemies
they need to listen now because we're
running out of time
absolutely thank you jack appreciate
your call and and i hope that helps a
little bit
all right next quarter that we have is
uh jake listening california
jake welcome to the program thank you
hi um i'm gonna i'm gonna get right to
the point
um because i would like to know if i
am saved um would you like background as
why i'm asking that question if you can
give it uh summarize it quickly yeah
okay because um well there's another
a pastor who he's actually he's
brilliant
and he has sermons on online which i've
read you might might even know him
i won't say his name um and
he asked the question how do you know
you're saved and i went through all the
criteria i really
you know really doubt according to what
he's saying that i am
saved um you know i'm still sinning
um i have doubts about
uh the truth of the bible um
but i am improving though and it's just
not like i'm i'm all the way in
and basically he says you really have to
follow the lord
um it's a gift but it's something it's
not that easy well
let's talk about that i that's a great
question jake and i think there's a lot
of people out there that are tuning in
right now that are going you know i feel
a little like that
how do you know you're saved and you do
we ever feel good enough
uh you know i think the key is that know
that jesus
desperately wants to save you that he
made every provision
to save the sins of the whole world in
other words he paid enough to cover the
debt for the sins of the whole world
he can certainly cover yours and if you
are willing
if you come to him with a willing heart
and you confess your sins
and you say lord i'm a sinner all my
promises are like ropes of sand
and but i want to be forgiven of my sins
i want to be in your kingdom will you
forgive me and give me a new heart
he will change your heart it may not
happen instantly
but you it's like a new birth well new
birth usually has nine months of
gestation
and then even the baby continues to grow
you come to christ as a new baby and
don't be discouraged if you
fall as you're learning to walk you keep
giving yourself to the lord if you sin
you repent
the bible promises he will if we confess
our sins he's faithful and just to
forgive us
you become his child he adopts you he's
not going to cast you off every time you
make a mistake
any more than any loving parent will
cast off their child
and so don't get discouraged you become
god's property
and the more you love him the better
you'll follow him if you don't
understand everything in the bible don't
be discouraged keep reading it your
faith will grow
you know we do have a book jake that we
want to encourage you to call and ask
for and anyone wanting to learn more
really gets the basics called three
steps to heaven
and it kind of tells us what we need to
do to
confess our sins to come into a saving
relationship with jesus and we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks
just ask for the book three steps to
heaven and we'll get it right out to you
yeah hey jake yeah are you still there
yes i am still here i maybe i misled you
with my question i'm it's not like i'm a
felon or anything
i'm talking about like i i dislike
people you know
and so you know you have to love your
your your neighbors
i love people and it's very hard for me
well you know what
i don't know join the club you know even
the disciples argued with each other
before the crucifixion
but i was just going to say that you
know i'd like to pray with you if that'd
be okay
and uh sure right now so you believe
that jesus died for your sins correct
yes well yes okay and you believe that
if you confess your sins he promises
to forgive you oh yes that's easy
okay well if you believe the word of god
it says that he cleanses you from all
unrighteousness and he gives you a new
heart
and you believe that and accept it and
you watch the holy spirit start working
in your heart
so could i pray with you before we go to
our next call would that be okay
yes father in heaven i just want to lift
up jake and i believe there's many
others listening right now that are
struggling they want to know that
they're saved and
i pray they'll make that decision to
come to you to ask you to forgive their
sins
to give them a new heart to adopt them
as
your children lord and and then begin to
lead them in that new
path of life and so give them the
assurance that you can finish the work
you begin
in their lives and that you will not
abandon them
we thank you and we pray this in jesus
name amen
amen all right well thank you jake get
that book pastor ross talked about and i
think you're going to be blessed three
steps to heaven yeah the number to call
is 800-835-6747 and again as for the
book it's called three steps to heaven
we'll be happy to send this to you jake
or anyone who calls and asks
we've got phil listening in tennessee
phil welcome to the program
thank you pastor ross pastor bachelor
yeah
my question is on um when thoughts
become sins
i just got like an example that i
thought of was you know like
if he's like a daydream a guy's out
running errands
he's going into a store outside the
store is some
craft things for sale something catches
his eye
she thinks his wife would really like it
so if he looked at his face he starts
smiling
uh he sees the price on it he thinks
it's really fair he's really smiling a
lot
he goes ahead and buys it he thinks that
she'll really like it it's a gift for no
reason
um maybe she'll cook my favorite dinner
and maybe we'll have some adult time
later together
so where's the sin in that but he's
married but what if that's a guy
that he's thinking about his girlfriend
in that where does the thought
or the temptation become a sin in that
all right well i think there's other
people out there with you that are
wondering
um you know at what point does a thought
become
a sin and and you know our minds if you
try to
figure out how many thoughts individual
thoughts go
screaming through a person's mind in a
day
it's incomprehensible no computer can
keep up with it well at least that's how
my mind is
and my mind's all over the place and
sometimes i'm on my knees and i'm
praying and talking to god i got a
thought going through my mind and i'm
going oh lord
forgive me how could i dare think that
and i'm talking to you
and you see you know because the thought
comes into your mind doesn't make it sin
it can make it a temptation but i think
a thought becomes
sin when you receive the evil thought
and you dwell on it and you ponder it
someone said you cannot keep the birds
from flying over your head
but you can keep them from making a nest
so if an evil thought let's suppose it's
you know a lot of people struggle with
impurity thinking about sex
and uh if you know especially you know
the forbidden variety
if you're not married and if the thought
comes into your mind
and you recognize that you got to go
well now wait a second
um lord forgive me and you just redirect
your mind to something else
sometimes i get i was out in the world
for my whole young life and i knew all
the worldly music out there and some of
the lyrics were just
uh diabolical i'll walk through a store
or somewhere and i'll hear some of those
old songs
and i get into my head and i start
humming it it happened to me today
well the way i deal with it is i start
singing a different song
thinking it initially is not a sin it's
is is your heart chasing after it and so
um
you know that's the that's the key i
think don't let it make a nest in your
mind
you know we do have a book it's called
is it a sin to be tempted
and it deals with this that's perfect
every christian you know if you're
trying to live a godly life
there's going to be temptation how do we
deal with that and i think everyone will
be
encouraged if you'd like to receive that
the number again is 800 800-835-6747
that is the resource phone line and the
book is called is it a sin to be tempted
and we'll get this to anyone who calls
an ass
we got uh bakim listening from new
jersey
became welcome hey how are you today
doing great
okay yeah i came across this verse i'm
trying to figure out what does it mean
it's proverbs 22
16 it says he who oppresses the poor to
increase his wealth
and he who gives gifts to the rich both
will come to poverty what exactly that
mean
that's great of course this is written
by solomon who was a very wealthy man
and
and first of all there's two principles
in there one is
and he links them together someone who
oppresses the poor in other words
they're taking advantage of the poor and
they're
they're grinding down maybe they've got
people that are they're
renting from them and they charge them
exorbitant prices and they charge them
exorbitant interest so that they can
make themselves rich in an unfair way
that person that's an evil behavior but
solomon then says it's equally evil
if a person is trying to manipulate the
rich by uh giving them
gifts to get their way you know it's
kind of like government bribes
both are bad and solomon was a king and
he was exposed to those two things in
his kingdom
so does that help or make sense become
yeah so so it kind of makes sense that
jesus stood out you know he didn't get
into
the politics of his day you know he
stood out of the politics it kind of
makes sense right
yeah yeah christ the only the closest he
ever came to politics when he said
render the seas of the things that are
caesar's and to god the things that are
god's
uh even pilate tried to engage jesus in
local politics he says are you a king
jesus said no not a king of this world
am
my citizens would fight and he let
pilate know look i'm not a threat to
your government
i'm a threat to the devil's government
and so yeah jesus tried to stay out of
that arena so to speak but um
you know certainly his teachings uh he
said i didn't come to bring peace but to
bring a sword
all right well thank you for your call
uh we've got henry listening in new york
henry welcome to the program
yes uh you agree evening thanks for
calling
my question is uh
when jesus christ comes no one knows
when he's coming back
it's written in the
how can he not know yeah good question
in matthew 24
jesus said no man knows the day or the
hour
but not the angels not even the son and
people are going what
jesus is there by the father
and he's god and god is all-knowing how
come god the father wouldn't let jesus
know or jesus would be
ignorant of something as important as
when he's going to return
why would the father not tell him
now jesus is simply saying when he was
on earth
and he was telling the disciples about
the signs of his coming
he said no man knows the day or the hour
and the angels don't know
not even the son in other words jesus
said i'm not going to give you the date
now there's two reasons for that one is
he was on earth
and he was a man when he was on earth he
in other words laid aside his divinity
so
as a man he did not take advantage to
all of this supernatural knowledge he
laid that aside
now in heaven in his glorified state i'm
sure he does know
but keep in mind there are conditions to
christ's coming
and one of those conditions was the
gospel of the kingdom was going to be
preached in all the world
and so he told the disciples look i
don't want you to say
you know be saying or here's the date of
my coming and you just wait to the day
before
like paying your taxes and then you get
busy said
no man knows a day be ready always
you know we do have a book talking about
the second coming it's called
anything but secret talks about signs
connected with the second coming and how
christ will come
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who asks the number is 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book anything
but secret i will be happy to send that
to
to you uh we've got matt listening in
canada matt welcome to the program
hey guys how's it going great and your
question tonight
yeah my question is based on isaiah 58
13. okay i was wondering if you could
lend your understanding
about that verse especially the part
where it says to not speak our own words
on the sabbath
um i was curious if that means like on
the sabbath we should only
talk biblical topics okay
we talked about general life as well
yeah let's let me read this to you and
of course a lot of people are
we got a lot of listeners on satellite
radio they're on the roads across the
country
and um so i want to read this isaiah
chapter 58 13
if you turn away your foot from the
sabbath when it says turn away your foot
people used to trample things that were
being disrespected
turn away your foot from the sabbath
from doing your pleasure
on my holy day and that of course is
you know it's it's a sacred time for god
turn away from the common interests and
common work
calling the sabbath a delight now that
answers a lot right there
we should delight in the sabbath he's
not saying i want it to be a drudgery he
wants it to be
a blessing not a burden the holy day of
the lord
honorable and you should honor him so
how do we honor him it's a day with god
not doing your own ways
people lay aside your regular secular
work
or finding your own pleasure seeking
your own pursuits some people say well
it's the sabbath face of my family and
i'm going to go snow skiing
and i say no that's not sabbath keeping
oh but we're out in nature i said no
you're not you're not keeping the
sabbath holy when you're doing stuff
like that
uh you know it's time to come together
and worship god you read in isaiah
chapter 58 it says all flesh shall come
together and worship
no i'm sorry isaiah 65 all flesh will
come together and worship before me
so it's a time to come together and
worship god
uh encourage each other in the lord we
shouldn't be talking about our own
you know work projects when he says
speaking your own words
but it should be words of of uh you know
glorifying god that doesn't mean you're
just quoting scripture after scripture
yeah i think it's also there the context
of that is it's not a day to plan
business where you know people would get
together and talk and plan and
figure out you know how much money they
can get for this it's
it's not a business kind of day so even
our words we want to be careful
that we don't um speak those things
that'll edify and encourage and lift one
another up of course there's nothing
wrong in asking somebody how they're
doing and
visiting with someone uh but i think
there it's more
focusing on speaking common things or
work related or business related things
that
people would often talk about during the
week you know we have a book
pastor ross it's on how to keep the
sabbath holy
and if don would like we'll be happy to
send you a free copy
yeah or anyone that has a question on
that the number is
seven and again 800-835-6747 ask for the
book how to keep the sabbath holy and
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks
um next caller that we have let's see we
got don listening in pennsylvania don
welcome to the program
hi and your question
well it's in the book of groups i've
been wondering about this for a lot of
years
it's where naomi sent ruth to
where he um was beating the wheat
and he was asleep and she had instructed
her to lay
at his feet and then there was a
covering over her or she pulled the
covering over her
and i was wondering what the
significance of that was or what that
meant yeah and you know there were some
customs back then
that there's some interesting customs in
the book of ruth
one reason we believe it's a true and an
inspiring book is it was very
perceptive about what the middle eastern
customs were
um they also had uh a custom where if
you did not
redeem your near kinsmen you would take
off your shoe
and you'd say i can't do it so the feet
were very important jesus washed the
disciples feet
and they had a custom now when boaz went
to sleep and they were actually i think
they were harvesting barley and she went
to the threshing floors a big flat stone
area where they would
shovel up the barley and they kept it
separated from the dirt and all the
workers
during harvest season they wouldn't even
go home they just stayed there until the
work was done
so he went to sleep and she was to go in
quietly uncover his feet laid his feet
and that was a symbol that she was
saying she was appealing for
his mercy and his recognition
when you go to someone's feet like that
and she was asking him to redeem
naomi and ruth because they were the
near kinsmen they had lost their
inheritance their their home there in
bethlehem when they
left i think 10 years earlier and so um
it was it was a custom back then that
when someone came to your feet
um it may have also been kind of a way
of her saying
i want to be your servant will you marry
me
so it's kind of that's kind of what you
get from the story but it's not all
spelled out distinctly
any thoughts well yeah you know i'm also
wondering she says
she uncovered his feet so he's sleeping
outside he's sleeping by the gray
we don't know how what temperature was
but if your feet are
um uncovered and it's cool it's probably
going to wake you up
so one way she was letting him know that
she was there uh but as you say if you
read on the conversation she actually
asked that um he take care of her
because he is the next of king
so um it's kind of interesting there
thank you don all right next quarter
that we have uh
time maybe for one more let's uh see if
we can use jeffrey welcome to um
bible answers jeffrey from washington
hello astrid hi we got about a minute
jeffrey can we do it
yes we can uh my question is pastor um i
was watching your
your teaching on on the angels so i was
wondering science mentioned that we will
only use
a very small brain do you think it is
god's plan
since that we couldn't see
the you of the androgen well yeah you
now i think jeffrey is referring to a
statement that i made that according to
neurologists that humans in their
lifetime
our brains are the capacity of our
brains when we're healthy
is much larger than most people use
it's incredible that you know some
people have a photographic memory you
think about it
six years old and they remember
everything they've ever done in their
life
how do you store all that information
and they say well that's nothing
there are some people who have actually
had ha it's called
hemispherectomy they have half of their
brain removed because of some
medical problem and they're able to
function with literally half of their
brain
and they still have a normal life and
all the functions transfer from one side
to the other and
so that's one reason that we know
evolution is not true why would god ever
have us
evolve and develop more brain why would
evolution never make us use
more brain 90 more brain than you use
except maybe we were meant to live
eternally and but i'd still need a
backup after a few million years i think
i'd
need to download some of that anyway hey
friends before we go off the air
and we do have important announcements
so don't don't change channels just yet
i want to remind you what we mentioned
at halftime
october 23 to november 14
in just a few weeks we're beginning
revelation now it is going to be a
bible study spectacular talking about
some of the most important prophecies
you find
in the book of revelation and the book
of daniel and other books of prophecy
and it's going to explain what in the
world is going on right now
and so everything's about to change
friends go to the website
and you can join this it's a free
seminar nobody's going to be begging for
money
we're going to be giving away a lot of
free materials and you can
participate in your church in your home
bible study group or just as an
individual
revelationnow.com go
join us now part of this free bible
study program
we're going to be doing 20 presentations
on bible prophecy
a lot of people charge for a program
like this it's all going to be
absolutely free
and after you go and you log on you say
wow this looks like it's going to be
exciting
then send the link to your friends and
your enemies well listening friends you
can hear the background music
if you've been blessed by the program
please keep us on the air go to
amazingfacts.org
and donate god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible
even better than before bible answers
live is produced by amazing facts
international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay
california
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets
political tensions are at an all-time
high does the bible have anything
to say about the times in which we are
living hi friends this is pastor doug
batchelor
many people are wondering if the world's
about to implode
some are fearful that global events
point to a coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy
study bible the updated hardcover
version is available at its lowest price
ever and includes the complete set of
amazing facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it
at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6740
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org